um talk about well first of all you
mentioned video games you uh during the
pandemic uh we got to see you on Twitch
a lot oh yeah you was gaming pretty
heavy I was getting heavy yeah was it
Apex Legends you were playing they're
still Apex that's still see you know
that's like for people who don't know
man Apex Legends is kind of like the the
the stepchild of the
the Video Game World because we always
hear about Call of Duty right oh yeah
Modern Warfare everybody's on [ __ ]
Modern Warfare and then you hear about I
mean like the over hype [ __ ] you know I
mean it's just like and then there's
like fortnite which is GTA that's 2K and
there's Cod and now if anything people
like mention fortnite or whatever you
know what I'm saying but those are like
the main games that people know but like
Apex is on the come up on the rise and
people don't even realize that like Apex
are just a better game you think it's
better than all those oh I wouldn't say
all the other games
um my producer that's all he [ __ ]
does then Cod absolutely he played
another place who's your man
great okay race man in the building man
now she's a a legend that you could
select in the game oh okay so she wanted
the OG Legends so when you play Apex
Legends you it's not do you build your
own character no no you don't you just
select from a roster of Legends that
they have yeah and if anything you can
put their own skin but they all got
their own different abilities like my
favorite who's yours mine is Mirage so
basically like I can like just send a
decoy and I have one Bryson tiller right
here and then I just walk to the
bathroom while you're interviewing that
person I was about to say do you kind of
wish you had that in real I do yes man
like I don't want to do all this [ __ ]
man just like let's send the [ __ ]
decoy out there yeah back in the day MF
Doom used to do that you know what MF
Doom is oh yeah so MF Doom he because he
he wears a mask yeah so he had a guy who
was built similar to him that would go
out there and perform some of his shows
under the mask and just lip sync and I
think I did that maybe one time with
Swan because there's one point where
people couldn't tell us apart yeah not
for a concert at all he wouldn't survive
out there
but when it came to like walking to a
club or something like I think we had to
use them as a decoy but wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait yeah my best friend
swine like you know I mean he had a he
had to go like when he was my dick you
had a club walkthrough booked no no no
no no no it was like I was I had we had
to get out of the club or something it
was just too crazy so I had to like so
you kind of like yo had the security
surround him yeah and I thought you were
like yo my guy pulled up to the club he
got the back end and he did don't and he
got the [ __ ] up out of there that sounds
like some Akon boost [ __ ] yeah well I
mean yeah but you know Akon's brother
really like you you know I'm sure in
like before the internet yeah before
like Instagram I could see that I could
see people pulling that type of [ __ ] off
nowadays not happening I don't think so
it's it's it's a little too everyone
everything's just so trans uh
transparent